Hello everybody
My name is Markiplier
And welcome back
to the world's...
...quietest...
...Let's Play.
It sounds like there's pop rocks in my mouth
*nasty chewing sounds*
Come along, little Johnny.
It has been... a while...
I hope you don't mind...
the...
bumpy ride that- *WHACK* -you are going upo--
*drop sound*
Johnny...
Come back here you little shit...
(sarcastic) Wow,
*Wait, HOW IN THE-!?*
It seems I found the secret to succ...
OOHH!
Five balls!
It seems my medical condition has worsened...
by a factor of 2
by a factor of 2.
by a factor of 2.5
*intense voice* NO!
You bag of tits!
You son of a *PUNCH* bitch!
*SQUELCH*
*WHOOSH*
*BOOM*
*CRACK*
*THA-THA-THUMP-THUMP-THUMP*
How dare you mash my face.
If I have to do this bullshit...
...again...
I'll tear off your entire ass...
and then feed it to yourself.
If you could stop...
*STAB STAB STAB*
Pooning...
pooning...
my butthole?
*STABBITY STAB STAB*
What did I just say?
My vengeance...
*CRACC* will be endless...
You will see horrors- *flashlight clicking off*
un- you, sack of fuck.
Little Johnny...
*WHOOSH* you will not mock-
Little Johnny. if you dodge this next one...
I will officially stop...
... hating on you.
Victory is assured,
there is no way that I can fuck this up.
*WHOOSH*
*SHING*
*SHATTER*
Little Johnny...
What have you done to become immune...
to my swords?
I don't like that- *SHLORP* NO!
no.. .no...
no... *demonic clown laugh* no...
*CLICC*
*woosh...*
*Creepy laugh from Jack, Wade, Tiny Box Tim, and pewds*
*More spoopy laughs*
*Laughing from somewhat subdudes... it's the gamegrumps*
Clown Arin: I'm gonna cum on your tits!
*Every clown of hell laughing*
*Okay... I ran out of sound effect ideas... so... Go subscribe to Markimoo and RushLight Invader for more comedy and animations...*